j'ai encore fait un rêve bizarre la nuit
dernière c'était agréable où est-ce que
tu rêvais de moi j'ai rêvé d'un homme
pauvre message qui changeait la vie de
notre ville j'ai très bien vu son visage
merci beaucoup d'être venu les amis et
bien j'ai un meeting au bureau avec des
acheteurs à 6h30 et il faut que j'aille
déposer des contrats dallas qui va
repartis tous ce que vous avez déjà eu
des problèmes de maladies infectieuses
dans le coin
tam a parlé de la nouvelle amy si tu ne
dis pas à débit je le ferais on est
marié depuis 19 ans qui partage partage
plus la même vision partage plus rien
tu peux t'en as tu fait un choix
et maintenant
il faut qu'on parle à cet homme c'est
lui c'est l'homme que j'ai fait dans mon
rêve
vous c'est comme un besoin de connaître
j'aimerais pourtant reconnaître
vous allez voir votre femme et lui
redonne foot rabais vous vous rendriez
vraiment service si vous pouviez être un
peu plus gentil ou poulet mon ami
il va falloir que je réfléchisse à ça
d'où vous venez après la mort de ma
famille le maître m'a mis dans une
petite cabane glissé rien gagner de
l'argent j'ai même un peu de respect des
déshérités des sans abri près de chez
vous jette complètement fêlé ou youtube
servir de leurs mains pour travailler il
ya des choses que vous devez savoir sera
j'ai fait beaucoup de mal vous n'êtes
pas une mauvaise personne et je suis
heureuse d'être judo était très sexy ce
que tu as fait aujourd'hui sortir avec
un sans abri c'était comment franchement
c'est surprenant
il ya des choses que vous devez savoir
sera elle était la seule personne qui
met mais assez pour ne pas laisser
tomber
je t'aime annie rey
ce que les
que vous soyez riche où que vous soyez
pauvres nous sommes tous les sens après
nous essayons tous de rentrer chez nous
denver a tout changé
nous n'aurions pas vécu ces moments
merveilleux
stop
- une bonne partie des autres membres ça
nous pose un problème que tu ramènes ne
peut pas les gros ici je peux lui dire
toi même il ya juste derrière toi
[Musique]